les revendications sont multiples et le
mouvement de la grève s'attaque à chaque
département pour les pompiers des
yvelines la principale requête concerne
le manque d'effectif 140 postes sont
demandés pour remplir les camions lors
des interventions
les délais d'intervention augmenté dans
tout le département dont cadet il y en a
pour qui ça n'a pas bougé et d'autres
qui ont pris 10 15 20 minutes
supplémentaires à des interventions du
fait de la disponibilité des pompiers à
cet instant dans le sens concerné c'est
de remettre en effectif suffisant dans
les engins comme c'est prévu ou un
fourgon incendie on doit de 6,2 dans
cinq quatre trois ça marche pas
forcément derrière le service n'est plus
du tout le même intervenir dans de
bonnes conditions c'est la volonté de
ces sapeurs la profession des pompiers
n'est pas encore reconnue comme
dangereuse et insalubres ce qui ne leur
permet pas de prendre leur retraite
avant 62 voire 64 ans on sait que
l'espérance de vie d'un pompier de 65
ans on a un métier qui est dangereux
pénible on intervient sur tout partout
pour tous même pour des missions qui ne
sont pas les nôtres on est exposé en
première ligne tout le temps ces
pompiers qui subissent des charges de
travail importantes mais aussi des
agressions lors des interventions ne
supportent plus leur rythme de travail
contacté par la rédaction la direction
du sdiss 78 n'a pour l'instant pas
souhaité s'exprimer sur le sujet la
grève des pompiers risque de
s'intensifier dans les jours à venir